Allah gives the solution for happiness
and the best is if you read
the book
70 major sin hadith of the prophet that
there are seven major sins Abbas says
may Allah be pleased with him 70 is more
closer to seven 70 major sin and this
are the major dos and don'ts Allah says
in the Quran you stay away from major
sins Allah will forgive your minor sins
I'll just point out a few of the major
dos and don'ts time is limited Number
one is
dos and don'ts in the kabay dos and
don'ts are mixed means if you do shik it
is the biggest sin so number one do is
believe in Allah
and the biggest sin is shik
as in partners with Allah subhana wa
tala so ins 4:48 so in chapter 4 116
Allah may forgive any sin if he pleases
but the s can never forgive
the number to do it is salah
salah your prayers and our prophet said
the difference between iman and kuf is
salah
the person that the thing that
differentiates a m and a kafir a muslim
and a non-Muslim is salah number three
is zakat every rich person who has a
saving of more than the nisab level of
85 g of gold should give 2.5% in charity
every lunar
Number four, Islam, fasting in the month
of Ramadan. Abstaining from food, drink
and sex from dawn up to sunset in the
month of Ramadan. Hajj, if you have the
means, perform Hajj.
Next is obeying and respecting your
parents. Surah 17:23 says that if one or
both of your parents reach old age,
don't say off to them.
Amongst the thing which is haram first
again the shik
if you do dawa if you don't remove the
shake from the mind of a non-Muslim your
dawa is useless number two today the
biggest killer of happiness you have
wars all over the world you have America
attacking Afghanistan killing hundreds
of thousands of people attacking Iraq
weapons of mass destruction fabrication
killing millions what is Israel doing in
Gaza more than 45,000 people killed
Most of them are children and women
that's also
recorded not recorded multiple times
more
than 100,000 seriously injured. What's
happening in Rohindia? What's happening
in Bangladesh? She hassa killed
thousands of Muslims. What's happening
in India? Muslims are being lynched.
What's happening in China? One solution.
Allah says in surah maida chapter 5
verse number 32 if anyone kills any
other human being unless it be for
murder or corruption it is as though he
has killed the whole of humanity and if
anyone saves an human being he saved the
whole of humanity if any Muslim or
non-Muslim kills any other innocent
Muslim or non-Muslim it is as though you
have killed the whole of humanity if
this worse every human being follows
terrorism will [clears throat] be
eradicated from this world and if you
save a human being you are saving the
whole of humanity.
Number three, black magic.
Number four, zena, adultery,
fornication. Allah says in surah surah
chapter number 17 verse number 32, come
not close to adultery or fornication
because it's an evil opening other roads
to evil.
Next is ribba. In the major sin,
fornication is number 10 in Imm
Abdhabi's book of Kabay. Number 12 is
ribba. Allah says in surah bakar chapter
2 verse number 278 and 279 if you give
up not your demands of interest of ribba
take notice of a war from Allah and his
if you have alcohol Allah doesn't wage a
war against you if you take ribba give
or take ribba Allah will wage a war
against you do you have the guts or the
capacity to fight Allah in his rasool
and Allah says alcohol is prohibited in
surah maza 5 verse number
Oh you believe most certainly toxicness
and gambling dedication of stone
divination of arrows these are Satan's
handiwork abstain from me that you may
prosper this was in brief about dos and
don'ts the solution for happiness I
would like to end my speech with the
same verse of the Quran I started surah
al assur chapter number 103 verse number
123 which says wal
By the token of time, man is very in a
state of flaws. Except those who have
faith, those who have righteous deed,
those who exalt people to truth, and
those who exalt people to patience and
pursuits.